Two neutron stars caught in a death spiral.
This massive kilonova explosion not only
sheds light on the creation of heavy elements
such as gold and platinum, it also provides
scientists with a unique insight into one of
the most mysterious objects in the universe.
Trying to imagine what a neutron star is
really like really challenges our
imagination. It also challenges our
theoretical physics.
We have to go to our computer models, our
mathematics, to have some estimate of what
this might be like.
Now, scientists don't have to rely on their
imaginations.
They can use hard data from the kilonova.
To work out what makes neutron stars tick.
There's so much information we got from
observing that one single event, that one
colliding neutron star pair.
Now, for the first time, we have an accurate
estimate of the mass of the neutron star and
the diameter. We can finally begin to piece
together how neutron stars really work.
They calculate the diameter is just 12.4
miles.
One mile less than the length of Manhattan.
Nailing down any physical characteristic is
really important.
And if there's going to be one, the radius
is a big one, because from there, if you know
the mass, you can get the density.
And if you know the overall density, you can
start to figure out what the layering inside
of a neutron star is like.
For physicists, the interior of a neutron
star is one of the most intriguing places in
the universe. You have to realize that the.
Conditions inside a neutron star are very,
very different than the conditions that exist
here on Earth. We're talking about material
that's so dense that even the nuclei of atoms
can't hold together.
With the neutron star. You're taking
something that weighs more than the sun and
compressing it down to be smaller than a
city.
It's so dense that if you tried to put it on
the ground, it would fall right through the
earth.
High density means high gravity.
Gravity 200 billion times greater than on
Earth.
Magic climbing up on a table in the surface
of a neutron star and jumping off.
You're going to just get flattened instantly
and just spread out on that surface.
So don't even think about trying to do push
ups.
Added to the intense gravity are hugely
powerful.
Magnetic fields.
Awesome x ray radiation.
Electric fields.
30 million times more powerful than
lightning bolts and blizzards of high energy
particles. For a space traveler, this is not
a good neighborhood.
If you were to find yourself in the vicinity
of a neutron star, it's going to be bad news.
First, you would be torn apart by the
incredibly strong magnetic fields.
Then the x ray radiation would blast you to
a crisp, and as it pulled you closer, its
intense gravity would stretch out your atoms
and molecules into a long, thin stream.
You would build your speed faster and
faster, and you would finally impact the
surface splatter across it.
And that process would release as much
energy as a nuclear bomb.
If I had the choice between falling into a
neutron star versus a black hole, I think I'd
pick the black hole because I don't really
feel like being torn apart by a magnetic
field and blasted with x rays.
On a cosmic scale.
Neutron stars may be pint sized, but they
sure pack a serious punch.
The secret to all this pent up power is
what's going on below the surface.
Armed with the new Kilonova data, we can now
take a virtual journey into the heart of a
neutron star.
First, we must pass through its atmosphere.
Now, it's not like the Earth's atmosphere,
which goes up like 100 miles on a neutron
star. The atmosphere is about this deep, and
it's extremely dense compared to the air
around us.
Below the compressed atmosphere is a crust of
ionized iron, a mixture of crystal iron
nuclei and free flowing iron electrons.
Now the gravity is so strong that it's almost
perfectly smooth.
The biggest mountains on the surface are
going to be less than a quarter of an inch
high.
A quarter inch mountain range may sound odd,
but things get even stranger as we go below
the surface. This is home to the strongest
material in the universe.
It's so weird.
Scientists liken it to nuclear pasta.
As we dive beneath the crust of a neutron
star, the neutrons themselves start to glue
themselves together into exotic shapes.
First, they form clumps that look something
like gnocchi.
Then deeper, the gnocchi glue themselves
together to form long strands that look like
spaghetti. Even deeper, the spaghetti fused
together to form sheets of lasagna.
And then finally, the lasagna fused together
to become a uniform mass, but with holes in
it. So it looks like penne.
This is pasta.
Nuclear style simmering at a temperature of
over 1,000,000°F.
Extreme gravity bends, squeezes, stretches
and buckles, neutrons creating a material
100,000 billion times denser than iron.
But the journey gets even more extreme.
Even deeper is more mysterious and harder to
understand.
The core of a neutron star, which is very
far away from these layers, which we call the
nuclear pasta.
It's perhaps the most exotic form of matter.
So exotic it might be the last bastion of
matter before complete gravitational collapse
into a black hole.
Data from NASA's Chandra Observatory suggests
the core is made up of a superfluid, a
bizarre, friction free state of matter.
Superfluids produced in the lab exhibit.
Strange properties such as the ability to
flow upwards and escape airtight containers.
Although our knowledge of the stars interior
is still hazy, there's no mystery about its
dazzling birth.
Forged into life during the most spectacular
event, the universe has to offer the
explosive death of a massive star.
Neutron stars spark into life amid the death
of their parent star.
They are the ultimate story of resurrection
or of life from death.
It's all part of a cosmic cycle.
Stars are born from giant clouds of very cold
gas.
Those clouds collapse under their own
gravity.
And the density of the core at the center of
that collapse starts to increase.
A star is a huge nuclear fusion reactor.
The force of its gravity is so powerful that
it fuses atoms together to make progressively
heavier and heavier elements.
The star fuses hydrogen into helium once it
exhausts its hydrogen.
Then if it's massive enough, it can start
fusing helium at its core.
Fusion continues forming carbon, oxygen,
nitrogen all the way up to iron.
Once the star has iron in the core, it's
almost like you've poisoned it because this
extinguishes the nuclear reactions in the
core of the star.
You fuse something into iron and you get no
energy.
All of a sudden, there's nothing to support
the crush of gravity.
No radiation pressure.
Pushing out means no pressure keeping the
outer regions from falling in.
And that's what they do.
As the star collapses in its death throes,
its core becomes the wildest, craziest and
freakiest pressure cooker in the whole
universe.
The ingredients are all in place.
Time to start cooking up a neutron star.